[Music]
mdma love potions could be available
within the next 10 years i don't need it
it could be available what do you mean
like
public sales tell us why you don't need
it joe doesn't need it so ship down the
industry how does love potions work what
is the love potion have you ever heard
of a love potion
like a roofie in harry potter
[Laughter]
because this is not what you used to
call them hey you're a slept on me this
guy is this guy's good
he's on to something here you could be a
world class so you you can get someone
to feel feelings of love and attraction
toward you
if you spike their thing
well what does mdma do what is it what
is it it releases mad [ __ ] endorphins
or in dopamines or whatever's in your
body
i second that so in essence chemically
speaking right it chemically
creates in a reaction that also triggers
a bit of things like oxytocin which is
like what they call like the cuddle
[ __ ] chemistry or whatever the [ __ ]
um that makes you feel a certain thing
right when you like hug somebody for
like you get oxytocin yeah your oxytocin
[ __ ] like releases or whatever yeah
and then you it's in essence you're
producing love in your body you're
producing the chemical
mainly i think it's serotonin
i'm not the [ __ ] sign [ __ ] but
basically what happens is when you feel
the feelings of happiness nurture love
whatever right those good warm fuzzy
feelings
they release this chemical in your brain
we have receptors called synapses they
[ __ ] dump a little bit of that [ __ ]
it sprinkles down they catch it and they
go ah so good but in this case what ends
up happening is they [ __ ] overload a
reign of this [ __ ] and then so you get
love's time 20.
wow i love mom so they basically say we
know enough about the neuro chemistry of
love to probably suggest some things you
could take to enhance your abilities to
find love or to increase the possibility
that you will stay in love when it's
getting a little bit tricky
from a scientific oh
so that's like a conceptual thing right
but from a more scientific angle trying
to say the same thing they have
chemically figured out how to release
the specific things like oxytocin by
using these types of pills that will end
up suggesting the feelings and emotions
of love but that's also there's a little
bit of a social dilemma in that because
uh let's say i take the drug and i
didn't mean to fall in love with nick
but because yeah you did feelings
came through can we not put the reality
soak city baby okay but because of the
drugs suddenly i'm in belief because
those feelings did happen but if i'm off
the drug and suddenly i don't have those
feelings i can't take my eyes off you
but 90s like weird signs i'm just saying
i saw a movie trailer about that today
with chris hemsworth and uh for a
netflix movie and the whole premise was
they're in a lab behind a computer and
there's um a guy and
miles tellers the actor and a female and
they're like talking behind the screen
and they're saying hey how do you feel
about this woman's attraction do you
think she's fine or whatever at a scare
from 110 and he's like oh she's like a
seven and he's like oh cool and they say
let's test the program and they turn up
these little notches and they release
some chemicals in the air and they start
falling in love with each other so i
guess this is like something that
is probably going to be in softer it's
pervasive it's pervasive they're making
movies about it
[Music]
what if you can't control like that who
it's directed to like in your example
right and it's like oh i'm just trying
to get [ __ ] ryan fall in love with me
so i spike his drink i go
and he drinks it and he [ __ ] looks at
nick [ __ ] me cutie got anthony what the
[ __ ] dude you gotta [ __ ] around i'm
taking all your dudes i'm taking all
your [ __ ] dudes bro
but if i'm like oh yes i do if i'm
drinking it wouldn't i just fall in love
with everybody in here because i'm just
[ __ ] maybe that's what happens it's
just not maybe you have to be alone in
the room what if it makes you
attracted to the opposite sex like let's
say if you're straight and now you're
attracted to a man
so then or if you're gay you become
straight yeah yeah will people use this
at like conversions if if it's gay in
the street there's no issue there
obviously
straight to gay now we got a prom
agree with this
well maybe it will not if you're tired
of population growth maybe it'll take
shape of like like let's say uh i
[ __ ] down there right now right but
all the guys i see i'm in like a homie
type of love endorphins
yeah it's not always homo when i drop e
and it's been a long time since i've
dropped it but i swear to god that was
all i wanted to suck everyone off yeah
yeah suck them all afterwards after we
dance for about
two hours straight
we just chill drink some water and then
when someone gives you water you're just
like thank you so much i can't believe
you just [ __ ] gave this to me like
you won the [ __ ] lottery right you
drink the water and you're just like oh
my god just hella grateful and you go
man you know what you're like my best
friend and i think that conversation
comes every single time yeah like my i
think you know what you're like my best
no you know what you're better than the
best friend you're like my brother yeah
and you're like should we start a family
together
like how many dicks gonna fit my mouth
at the same time
these are kind of questions everyone
becomes family on mdma yeah on mdma
i feel love but i don't necessarily feel
horny so that's why i think that even
the uh the basis of this it's like um
it's like the way that i understand like
weed for example weed doesn't
immediately make me like hungry or
sleepy or whatever like the connotations
are it emphasizes what i currently am it
heightens it so if i'm already tired
then we will relax me more but if i'm
like thinking about something and i like
smoke weed or something like that i'm
more into what i was wanting to do so
i'll assume love potions or or things
that are like you know altering that
kind of like that biohack that
neurochemistry maybe function the same
way i don't think it's gonna put
delusions right where suddenly you fall
in love with something that's like
inanimate or whatever but rather if you
already had sentiment if anything it
maybe just like amplifies or triggers
that in such a way that it can release
that's cool
i got the best business idea okay
so buy a plane yeah yeah
because you know those those chinese
massage places right oh god they're
super they're they're super cheap
they're like 20 bucks foot massage right
damn you know how they can make more
money is you [ __ ] roll
and then you get a massage there
call it stop chop and roll or something
like that do you know what the problem
with that is with the accent too but the
problem with that if everybody rolls and
they go into the massage places they're
gonna be like no harder a little harder
i can't feel it oh is it gonna be too
like much of a nuisance no no like you
need like getting a massage on on e is
probably the best thing in the world you
can get like beat up and you're like
yeah a lot
why did they just do that
what why don't they just do that it's
like it seems like a no-brainer at race
places there's like massage booths
from massage therapists you gotta go
stuff in there might as well throw some
e in there some hand jobs have you guys
done this before wait what e and then
got massage i have massage illegal stuff
no you mean a happy ending the pancake
ones oh no not happy ending only blow
jobs
whoa is that not what it is no that's
different no that's not a happy ending
happy ending is more of a that's like
full service yeah really give you blow
jobs my friend is a very notorious uh
happy ending person i don't like going
to these places happy ender is his name
is his name watson imagine like finding
out you're notorious and then you
realize it's for that
he's notorious because he is the bert
swan he knows he knows all the places in
la he goes oh no don't go to that city
that place is good and then i i was
asking about wait are they the same
old ladies that do your back and goes
yeah and i'm like oh and he goes why do
you care like what they look like
they're just jacking you off you're not
having sex with them and i'm like
that my friend is not how i roll like i
need a like i can't get horny when and
especially because you know he's not
asian so maybe for him like does it
disconnect yeah cause for me that's like
my [ __ ] grandma or aunt right that's
all right too yeah you know joe didn't
even think britney spears was hot in the
90s so like we're [ __ ] you didn't
think britney spears was hot in the 90s
look see
see give me baby one more time eric
i that's pete half different tastes
he swallows it all i have different
tastes
it was okay i mean he was the marketing
was so strong it was hard to say she was
in the 90s i liked francine d okay okay
magazine girls
okay so i wasn't into the white girl
just chill all right i get it girl next
door was not for you because those were
my girl next doors oh yes
atd was nobody's girl next door wasn't
shanghai lee in girl next door next to a
nuclear power plant
they're good
i didn't like pop women because their
music sucked [ __ ] biggest titties
i've ever seen in the 90s she was
creating a lad that [ __ ] yeah dude she
was definitely near some power line so
this this friend of mine so he would go
to all these places and he would just be
like yes like sometimes like if you just
want an extra massage and then finish
after they'll tell you and i'm like but
they're like they're like grandmas dude
well they're [ __ ] there's a website
isn't there like tells you it like rates
massage probably based on the girl that
like they [ __ ] really yeah but the happy
ending places yeah rub maps rub match
dot ch they uh touch ch
after a massage they jack you off that's
a that's a that's a happy ending wait
what after a hat after a massager
after a [ __ ] they jack you off get
this
that's a happy ending
it's not it's not sex and sucking and
stuff oh yeah yeah yeah that's an
unhappy ending
clearly
that's called a fantasy
joe the current expert on all these
topics i think it's a ch because it
can't be an american website or we'll
get take it down um china
china or chicago
wow let's investigate webmap
we this has gone patreon
rug maps rub
because it literally is like it's fun
it's a map of getting rubbed off yeah so
you'll just look at your local area and
then the reviews are like oh ask for
cindy she had the smoothest hands yeah
honestly i bet i bet reading the reviews
are interesting though to see like what
these guys are really or what these
people are like why would you want to
share the girl that is your favorite you
got to put i'm over 18 on the website to
enter if you don't like sharing your
favorite restaurants that's like a yelp
you know all right so let's see
california let's let's look at the
closest one and tell all of our friends
okay dude let's drive by
all right oasis spa on jefferson
that's that's in temecula that's a shout
out
shout out oh okay i see one right over
here that was three by the way
boulevard i'm not going to say the name
that's kind of far but reader review
yeah let's read it we have to read
in order to read the review the [ __ ] out
of here
well how much is the premium 20 credits
it's 26 a month god damn 12 month deal
for 200. okay i'm into that maybe i
could look at the comments maybe
comments you're still getting someone no
okay
it's not working
asian after pressure in los angeles
sorry guys
so yeah went in this morning at 2 30 in
the afternoon till afternoon i don't
know he's probably drunk
um yeah um met rosie she was great and
her face is great 52 years old
um she was really nice she gave me a
really nice deep tissue massage i kept
winking i kept winking and winking and
winking
no response
i look up at rosie
and i'm winking and pointing at my the
eye that i'm winking with
and still no response she's not moving
her hands towards my genitals this is a
novel
a lot of these guys they the reviewers
take their job they they they love this
stuff they want to paint a picture it's
like a really yuppy view finally i had
to just reach down and start jerking it
myself at that point rosie exited the
room
so there yeah there it is
yeah i don't think uh i don't think
that's a good one that's a that's a not
not a good review can't believe yelp
posted that
did they get like half a star
i don't know
he said four stars we'll come back again
so like so the the reason everyone came
forward the reason this website got
popular
i think uh sub smoke right because the
detectives would use it to find the
[ __ ] oh my god human trafficking it's
like so [ __ ] it's like right there
but you want to pay the premium
membership but they had to go undercover
absolutely not 200 for the year like a
roadblock on the investigation you're
looking to get money from the evidence
you don't have any budget for this
up the chain for that kind of funds oh
god i gotta get a subpoena for this they
just defunded the police how the [ __ ]
are we supposed to investigate
[Music]